today's one of the biggest news days in
a long time in addition to the abrupt
unilateral ending of the House
Intelligence investigation into Trump
Russia Donald Trump has fired a
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson and is
going to be replacing him with CIA
director Mike Pompeo really the pinnacle
of stability in the White House right
incredibly stable circumstances there
over the weekend it was announced that
Rex Tillerson was canceling some events
in Africa because he was ill we now know
or at least are being told that on
Friday Tillerson learned that Trump was
firing him so was that announcement
about his illness real was it a cover-up
of the fact that he had been fired but
it hadn't been publicly announced yet we
don't really know right now but an
interesting little element of this is
that Jena Haspel is going to she is the
deputy CIA director she is going to be
stepping up to run the CIA and there is
already if you look at Drudge Report
comm there's already a counter
distraction here where to take attention
away from the pathetic instability of
what's going on in trumps cabinet Drudge
and other right-wing news are touting
how Trump has done something amazing he
is appointed the first woman ever to run
the CIA which is true and it's all fine
well and good except that a MS Haspel is
known in some circles as MS torture and
we're going to be talking about that
later on in the week the official
reasons that we're hearing for Tillerson
being fired are that there are going to
be trade negotiations happening as a
result of these tariffs that Trump is
putting in place there are going to be
possible talks with North Korea and that
bottom line Trump in Tillerson just
don't see eye to eye on some of this
stuff and I would argue that's mostly
because Trump doesn't understand
anything and that really they're going
to need someone in there a secretary of
state
who's going to basically be a yes person
for Trump and Mike Pompeo is a great
candidate for that that being said we
learn from Rex Tillerson spokespeople
that he didn't speak to President Trump
before the firing he was unaware as to
the reason for the firing and learned
about it initially apparently through
social media although that certainly
calls into question some of the timing
elements and there's still questions
about the timing right
the other possibility if we don't
believe that this was communicated to
Tillerson on Friday another possibility
is that I told you last week about the
poisoning using a nerve agent of a
former Russian spy
in the United Kingdom the UK has put out
a report saying that Russia has its
fingerprints all over it Rex Tillerson
has accepted that Russia has its
fingerprints all over it
even though the White House has not and
again purely speculation but maybe
another reason why this might have what
really we've speculated about for a
while the possible departure of
Tillerson has accelerated or at least
taken place now Tillerson becomes the
shortest serving Secretary of State
dating all the way back to the 19th
century I think to the 1880s super
stable folks never been a more stable
cabinet than this one this is also I
believe part of the distraction campaign
because in addition to the House
Intelligence Committee Republicans
unilaterally ending their investigation
into Trump Russia something major must
be about to happen here right robert
muller must be very interested in
speaking to Rex Tillerson would be my
guess and what we're dealing with here
here's the difficulty right that we're
dealing with at the show and I know
people in the audience are dealing with
as well there's this constant stream of
just insane breaking stories
that's almost paralyzing in a way it's
very difficult to keep perspective about
the absurdity of what's going on because
none of this is normal right events that
in most administrations would happen a
couple times a year are happening almost
daily and by the way
Pompeyo as Secretary of State is a
disaster right Pompeo is not a guy that
we talk about that much but he is an
Islamophobe along the lines of take your
pick right Sebastian Gorka Michael Flynn
Pompeyo loves this lunatic Frank Gaffney
Pompeyo was part of the movement that
was regularly implying that Obama either
either is Muslim or prefers Islam to
Christian
he suggested that American Muslims need
to prove their loyalty to the United
States in a way that has never been
required by him or or suggested by him
of Christians or American Jews or even
American atheist or agnostics this is a
disastrous direction diplomatically in
addition to being more of the same chaos
and it's likely not the end because the
rumor continues to be out there that
Michael Flynn's replacement National
Security Adviser HR McMaster is also
going to be leaving soon so it is total
chaos don't believe for a second that
this is stable and don't believe for a
second that this could be might not be
part of a distraction campaign a
preemptive one my feeling is we're gonna
be hearing something big from Robert
Muller very very soon the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad